good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about why and how to be
more creative creativity is the variable
of success all the strategies you create
come to the punchline this is a creative
process this show this content content
isn't is a creative output and
everything you plan to that moment you
could have the greatest strategy ever to
ask that girl out right ever like play
about everything but that moment where
you go in for the ask that content is
the variable possibly of a yes or no
rain there's other variables but you
know creativity is the absolute variable
like you might have understood that who
you're going after what to do when to
release that video game let's make it
Steve asked but if the if the graphic
suck though the gameplay suffer if it
sucked
like creativity is the variable of
success in our society including things
that we don't have control of like if
you weren't just born gorgeous if
there's just a massively good-looking
dude right you your strategy might have
sucked on that a scout but your
creativity the creative maybe the word
sucked but what you said might have just
been enough like you're just a pretty
boy you're just pretty I mean you know
how that is Stefan I mean guys got no
game but he wins he's just pretty that's
I mean that's that's real and and you
know it's funny actually using looks and
the way you spit game to girls is
actually a tremendous concept of
strategy and creativity like the way
ugly dudes get chicks is strategy and
and the creativity of their words and
charisma just the way it is
always when you find something you love
you become present in that gift in other
words you make it a song it's great the
music comes and the world moves slow the
world moving slow you've been in a car
accident the world's move slow right so
it's why you meditate to slow the world
down so you can see the miracles that
are unfolding in front of you instead of
missing them the fluctuations of the
mind the cause of suffering in a quiet
mind is the cause of happiness and
creativity you can only be creative in
the moment can't be creative in a future
you know so you have to be present and
you have seconds of presence and so the
goal is to expound on those seconds it's
only in the present moment can you be
creative and every entrepreneur needs
that innovation that moment those aha
moments you'll never have an aha moment
in the future or in the past so I just
keep saying that to entrepreneurs I keep
trying to remind them sit still let the
brain reboot let the mind settle you
become a much better at your job
hey guys Tara here for dnews with yet
another reason to get up off your butt
and move if you're like me you probably
spend several hours a day in front of a
computer and every so often you just
feel that need for a jolt of creative
inspiration well a new study from
Stanford University shows that walking
might actually be the best way to go
about that the study looked at 176
college students who were engaged in
some kind of creative exercise well
either sitting or walking and they
divided them into four groups so half
were inside either sitting or walking on
a treadmill and the other half were
outside either walking or being pushed
on a wheelchair to simulate the visual
sensation of walking they found that
regardless of whether the person was
inside or outside the simple act of
walking significantly boosted their
creativity and that creativity continued
even after they sat down perhaps more
surprising is that the people inside
walking on the treadmill we're facing a
completely blank wall with no
stimulation whatsoever and they still
produced twice as many creative
responses than people who were sitting
either outside or inside so walking
induces creativity that is the take-home
message of this study did you know that
you can increase your intelligence and
creativity by
exercising your brain in a different way
here's some good news according to all
the science and research over the last
two years you are a potential genius you
have within you right now incredible
reserves of brain power that you have
Italy fail to use you have sufficient
knowledge and intelligence right now to
overcome any obstacle to solve any
problem and to achieve any goal that you
can set for yourself what this means is
that your IQ is not fixed the more you
use your brain the more you can use it
the smarter you get the smarter you get
the more you learn the more you can
learn to unlock your inner genius you
need three things these are our first
intensely desired goals second you need
pressing problems and third focused
questions one good idea is all you need
to change the future of your business
and your life and you stimulate these
ideas by focusing and concentrating your
mind on your goals on your problems and
on key questions here's a simple
exercise that will change your life as
it has changed mine and thousands of
other people take a sheet of paper write
your current goal or problem at the top
of the page in the form of a question
for example you could write how can we
double our sales over the next 24 months
you then force yourself to write 20
answers to that question this is not
easy the first time you do it believe me
nonetheless by disciplining yourself to
write at least 20 answers to that
question you will be absolutely amazed
at the quality of the answers that
appear on the page before you this is
called mind storming sort of like
brainstorming it's one of the most
powerful creative thinking exercises
ever discovered and all it takes is a
piece of paper a pen and a few minutes
of your time once you've written down 20
answers and you can write more answers
if you like but 20 is the minimum go
over your list and so
one answer which you can implement
immediately the faster you implement
this idea the more ideas that will come
to you ask yourself this question on a
regular basis what one problem if I were
to solve it would have the greatest
positive impact on my business or you
can write what one goal if I were to
achieve it would have the greatest
positive impact on my sales and
profitability whatever your answer is to
that single problem or question write it
down develop twenty answers and then
take action you will be amazed at the
results when I felt called into the
ministry at 17 and I sat down with my
father who my father is 90 years of age
today still active for sure that dumb
ministry yes your fathers and I think 91
is it 91 so and my dad said John if
you're going to be in a ministry and if
you're going to teach you have to
constantly fill yourself up with
thoughts ideas reading and he said don't
ever let the don't don't ever let the
well run dry he said I know a lot of
people they they fill themselves up at a
young age but then they don't keep
refilling themselves they get I remember
he Houston I remember is the number so
well are 17 said 65 they get 65 and they
have nothing to say well I turned 65 it
and and and I've always had a fear of
having nothing to get because you cannot
give what you didn't have
so the compelling desire in the
beginning was to keep my wealth fill
what I didn't understand is that would
be the source of my creativity that
would be the source of almost everything
almost everything price absolutely
almost every good thing that's happened
to me is because of that advice of my
dad to be a student to be a learner to
ask questions I discovered that what I'm
talking I'm not learning anything but
what I'm asking questions I'm learning
everything and so every person is my
teacher every person has something that
they know that I need to know that's my
basic thought is when I have five
minutes with somebody I want to find out
as quickly as I can what they know
because they have something I need to
know and the quicker I know them the
quicker I can ask the question so they
can help me how much critics
showing in your work so if you created a
PowerPoint or keynote presentation
lately how creative was that
presentation and don't give me oh I just
slapped it together because I was I'm
always busy and I'm under a lot of
stress tonight my time lines are short
no that could be true for one project or
two but over the span of your work how
crazy is expressed have you been and if
you haven't been don't blame your boss
don't blame your work don't blame
anything other than your inability to
have the will to do it and I really mean
that with true respect to you a lot of
people fool themselves and they take the
victim role in life well you don't
understand my boss Brendon no I've had
bad bosses too
your boss has nothing to do with how
much you creatively express yourself and
if you believe it's true then you're
just living in fear he's like well I
can't if I create express myself I'll be
fired then you know what go get your ass
fired it will be the best thing you'll
ever happen in your entire life because
you know what then you'll say okay well
what's true for me well if I if you're
getting rejected because you're being
who you truly are and adding the value
you know you creatively can do then
guess what that's just a divine
indication that you need to go find
another level of community if you're
being rejected for being creative then
you're in the wrong place you need to
find a new community a new job a new
role do it responsibly but start seeking
right now a place where you can truly
express your art your ideas your mind
your vision otherwise you know what
you'll feel like at the end of your life
become do you feel like you just went
with the flow you did what everybody
else expected Divya you never brought
your mind your spirit your genius that
divine spark that says you know I'm
unique you never brought that into your
work and you will regret it and I say
that with respect because I've sat with
people at the end of their lives who
look back and thought I wish I brought
more of me to life
you know there's seven billion people on
the planet here you are just you there's
only one of you your ideas are unique
even if you don't feel like they are
they are the way that you express them
the way that you believe them the way
that you pursue them that's gonna be
unique than anybody else so bring more
creative expression
to your work and then you could
experience a little bit more of those
joys of life thank you guys so much for
joining me I made this video because
Emanuel Hernandez asked me to so there's
a topic that you want me to cover in the
next edition of believe life leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know which of
the points resonated the most with you
leave it in the comments and I'll join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you soon